[Music]
um
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
bye
you
[Music]
[Music]
all right hey everybody here we are we
are back
it's monday it's the last day of august
and i am always so happy
when august is gone yeah because it
actually beginning of the month's almost
payday
well that to you but it's like it that
almost means even though technically
it's still going to be hot here for like
several more months it
kind of sort of symbolically means that
summer is over and i hate summer so
yeah you know so i'm very happy to see
like yeah i'm just i'm already
pretending it's fall i already i had my
september calendar drawn up like
a week ago because i was so ready to get
rid of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
well we got 10 we got 10 of them in
there now yeah so
here let me uh put this there okay get
that going all righty
so today we are going to talk about a
little movie called
one bedroom yes br okay
yeah let me give a little background of
this this actually came out in 2019
now interestingly when we were going
through a thing where we were um
renting movies off the xbox and like we
would go through there and like see
the new movies this was one of the ones
that was like on my list to do and this
was like a few months ago
i think the reason like it looked really
good but like the reason that i didn't
watch it
was because in the trailer um
you know that something really bad is
gonna happen to a cat
and so i was just like i was like never
in the mood to
like watch it because i didn't see that
part it must i must i think that was
like near the beginning when you were
still
okay yeah that was only like 20 minutes
into the movie yeah
it's a weird movie this uh if you're
into if you know anything about
scientology you'll like the movie yeah
it's like i don't want to
well yeah i i kind of wanted i i was
going to say i don't want to spoil too
much about it
but it's hard to yeah i mean that's kind
of spoiled about it
well now you know pretty soon that
something like that's going on
that's the attraction of the movie woman
falls into this [ __ ] bizarre ass cult
and it's like it's pretty it's like a
horror movie
it is a horror movie yeah it's i mean
it's more psychological horror but there
is
um some kind of she's [ __ ] with me
again this early in the goddamn thing
hey stop
she's trying to get me to go well
because she was sleeping in there on the
bed with you and then she was mad
because you got up and left yeah
you're not allowed to leave you got to
stay there what's up next to her she's
got this thing
she'll go up to any kind of bookcase and
go
she'll look at me she's like look i'm
being bad yeah she's like whoever
stopped me
because she wants to wrestle she's
incorrigible yeah
all right let's get back to the dude
yeah look at her look what is she doing
oh my trying to dig through the books
yeah she likes she likes the sound that
it makes i guess
but yeah so finally um so i had seen the
trailer before and i'm like oh i can't
stand when like bad stuff happens to
kitties i don't give a [ __ ]
they can like [ __ ] up all the people
they want but it's like when they start
doing
bad stuff to kitties i'm just kind of
like i don't know i'm gonna have to be
like in a particular mood to watch this
so i didn't watch it i didn't watch it
for a really long time and then i saw
that it had just come up on
netflix like they just added it the
other day so i said well i guess that's
some kind of sign so i guess i'll
finally get around to watching it and
then i'll just have to like
steal myself like through that part
because it's really upsetting like i
said i could watch pretty much anything
in a horror movie except bad stuff
happen
to animals and anything to do with poop
or vomit other than that i can watch
pretty much anything
but yeah so be warned uh if you don't
like seeing bad stuff happen to kitties
bad stuff's gonna happen kitty
got her scared yeah i scared you she was
scared of the garbage she was scared of
the garbage truck this morning
yeah she tried to [ __ ] just throw
herself through the damn glass door
well she wanted to go outside on the
porch this morning and then the garbage
truck came by earlier scared that
garbage and she does not like the
garbage so she was like
oh my god oh my god it's gonna eat me
okay you come here you come here
come here
come here she's very terrible
yeah you're gonna have to chill out yeah
calm down it's all right i was talking
about
like before the movie came on i told
pookie i said i think something bad is
gonna happen to a kid you might want
not want to watch it so she went in the
other room but yeah so
so the premise of this movie is that
there's this girl named sarah
and she um implication being that she
has come from like kind of a wealthy
family but i guess her dad
is kind of a dick or they don't really
get along i guess like the dad was
cheating on the mom like when the mom
was dying of cancer or something like
that and this
daughter hasn't really forgiven her and
there's also um forgiving him rather
so i think there's kind of a thing where
the dad is kind of like spoiled her but
she wants to prove
that she can live independently and he
doesn't think that she can
so she basically drops everything and
moves out to la
to pursue her dream of being like a
costume designer or whatever
so she goes to la she gets like a temp
job and she um is gonna do like some
schooling there or whatever for the uh
you know for the clothing design or
whatever and so she's looking for an
apartment
and it so happens that she comes by this
building that's having an open house
with an apartment that is apparently
like pretty reasonable rent for the area
so she goes into the open house into the
apartment and it's like a really nice
apartment but there's like a whole bunch
of other people walking around there
she's like oh man i'm never gonna get it
like with all these people
but then the guy who's the apartment
manager is like oh you know it's
it's not first come first serve you
should fill out a thing and you know
maybe you'll get it
so as it goes on she does end up getting
the apartment and she's very very happy
about it so she moves into the apartment
now at first i mean you know this is a
horror movie
so you know some bad shits can happen
but i liked that
for a long time you're not sure exactly
what it is
because it's like it's a little bit like
stepford but not
that overt like you know what i mean
like everybody seems really friendly
really welcoming but not in a not in a
really weird way not at first
so she kind of comes in and like
everybody in this building is like you
know
oh we really try to make this a
community like make this a neighborhood
and we want everyone everyone's super
nice to her and everything like that
there's just this one kind of creepy guy
that only has one eye
but you know this older lady that lives
there that like used to be an actress or
whatever she's like oh he's just sad
like his wife died
you know not too long ago so don't be
too hard on him he's not creepy he's
perfectly fine and all this other stuff
they're talking about the frazetta thank
you thank you for the compliment but
yeah
it's a it's on it's a canvas it's on
canvas yeah
okay i know she keeps scratching yeah
stop
it so the first things that happen like
i said
at first everything seems uh pretty
copacetic like everybody seems cool
you know it's a nice place now one thing
is that they uh it says on the lease
that you're not supposed to have any
pets
well she has a cat a little orange kitty
named giles
and she lies and says that she doesn't
have a cat
uh but so she kind of sneaks him into
the apartment right
so always from the beginning i'm like
dread and just like what the hell is
going to happen to this cat even though
i kind of knew because it was in the
trailer
so at first the only [ __ ] that happens
is that
she's you know laying in bed at night
and she hears these really weird
noises like almost like [ __ ] like the or
the plumbing like creaking in the walls
or something like that
and it's so loud that it keeps her awake
so she's like
you know [ __ ] up her job she forgets
about stuff like to do with her school
like she misses deadlines and things
like that because she's tired all the
time
and the weird thing is when she starts
asking other people if they heard the
noise of the pipes and everything like
that
nobody seems to have heard it um so
that's a little strange
and so as that goes she's getting more
and more frazzled more more tired she's
like man i just you know she has to get
[ __ ]
uh earplugs and everything but you know
for the first half hour
you're not entirely you know something's
wrong but you don't know exactly what
and then it comes the thing where the
bad thing happens to the cat because
somebody like one of the neighbors like
uh slips something under a door like
with the pet policy and
like write something on it like some of
us are allergic you selfish [ __ ] or
something like that
and she gets kind of upset about it and
then that night
something really really bad happens to
giles the cat
and then something really really bad
happens to sarah
now like i said i didn't know where this
was going
and i liked that so like i said you
saying that uh it's a cult i mean that
that's kind of like a spoiler because
it's probably better to go into this
not knowing exactly what's going on i
didn't know if this was like a
rosemary's baby situation
i didn't know if this was supernatural
situation i didn't know i didn't know if
everyone was robots i didn't know what
the hell was going on
and that was kind of cool that like kept
me really interested yeah they were
robots they were based on scientologists
and it's like it's funny because the
more like the more it goes
the more it goes into it the more it
goes into it
i'm sitting there like looking at some
of the [ __ ] that they're putting her
through and i'm like this has got to be
based on scientology it's got to be
yeah i mean just the way i mean it could
be based on some other [ __ ] too but it's
like
just the way that they're also kind of
nexium a little bit yeah a little bit
too
it's kind of like because everybody's
trying to give her this book
like this phd wrote they have like these
the school at the apartment building
where like they're telling
all the kids like and the old guys like
on the tv like telling them about his
four pillars and
all this other because it's not a
religious cult but it definitely does
come across
you know and they hook her up to like
[ __ ] a lie detector and her asking
her about her sex life and all this
other kind of [ __ ] that's right so like
i said that's right out of scientology
and
i think that um i didn't read like a
great deal of reviews about this except
for one and the one review that i read
didn't mention it
but i did feel like because this is
something that happened
to a lot of younger actors that went to
la
like to be in the movie business or
whatever and then they ended up getting
sucked into scientologists
because they would set up like science
like acting classes and all that kind of
[ __ ]
um so i felt like this was kind of that
the the guy that wrote and directed this
whose name is david
marmer by the way i think this is his
first movie um
i think that's probably where he got the
idea it's not exactly the same but it
was similar enough that i was like that
had to be where he got the idea from
yeah but um yeah i really really liked
this movie and i really liked the end i
really liked how it was resolved
it's pretty short it's only like an hour
and 30 minutes long
and i didn't really think it needed to
be any longer or shorter than that i
thought it was really good it didn't
drag
um you know that was like i said it was
just this whole creepy thing where you
weren't entirely sure what was going on
or what the people's end game was or
how extensive this [ __ ] was that was
going on and so i really really liked
the suspense also the
um the girl that played the that played
sarah
um i'm not sure i think her name is
nicole bryan
bloom um she was great because a lot of
the i mean a lot of the [ __ ]
in the movie was kind of like on her
shoulders because a lot of it was
like her face like close-ups of her face
like her reactions of like the [ __ ] that
was going on
and i like the way they portrayed her
at the beginning is kind of like this
spoiled little rich girl who was trying
to go out on her own for the first time
but she was also very
accommodating so i feel like she was
targeted specifically because she wasn't
used to like standing up for herself and
she was used to just like going along
with what other people told her to do
yeah so i really liked like the way they
did like the
you know the the arc of her personality
like as she kind of got sucked farther
and farther into this [ __ ]
i do have to disagree a little bit
though it was a religious cult it just
wasn't christianity
all cults are religious all of them
i suppose yeah i mean even the army had
elements of religious cult or
the the you know the infantry did
costumes rituals you know what i mean
[ __ ] rites of passage
if again there there were things kind of
like kind of like holy scripture
uh even corporations have elements of
cults and religions to them
it's all religion yeah but i mean it
wasn't like
it wasn't a christian time that's what i
meant it was but it's religion that's
what i meant
i meant it was like a scientology or
like a corporate type of
sort of right and and um
scientology is definitely a religion
definitely it's a ufo cult
that's what it is yeah uh mixed and i
think nexium was a religion
too yeah any kind of hardcore
programming
that any hardcore training program that
changes who you are
and gives you abilities and improves you
or
rebuilds you it's a big eligibility a
bit big
there's a big element of religion in it
because there's
faith penance all kinds of stuff just
call it something else
yeah you know and i experienced that in
the infantry
each little unit was a [ __ ] different
cult a different warrior cult
they all had their own [ __ ] tribal
[ __ ]
uh uh what do you call it tribal uh
cat cannon you know their war history
what battles they were in and everything
it's all just part of it yeah and
corporations are exactly like that
yeah at the higher levels so
everything's pretty much occult
yeah you can look at it that way and
everything has l i think it's
fascinating a lot of people are very
uncomfortable with religion
i like religions i think they're [ __ ]
crazy
i also think that they kind of work they
do what they're supposed to do
they're supposed to just comfort people
in hard times and
uh give people a value system
and uh help them face death that's
really what it's about
and how to get through life it's a
substitute for a government
yeah and uh both can be abused
both of them can be abused beezness asks
does it show real cat abuse no of course
not
um but you know that you see the cat and
she's like super into the cat
uh you know because that's like her
little buddy because she's like all
alone out here in l.a
and um then i mean obviously it's not
real
and you don't see somebody doing
something to the cat you just see the
aftermath of what happens to the cat
and like i said it's in the trailer um
so
you know if you want to go watch the
trailer you'll get what i'm
driving at but this it's funny because
when i watched the trailer
like a long time ago that was one of the
reasons that i'm like i don't know i'm
gonna have to really be
fortified if i want if i'm gonna watch
that because that's like real like i
just said
that's really upsetting dogs too it's
like any time that you know anything bad
is done to animals in a movie
even if it's not real i know it's not
real um except for if it
unless you're cannibal holocaust but um
you know
it's it just really really bothers me
like i said you can [ __ ] up all the
people you want i don't care but
leave the kitties and doggies alone
please and the and the lizards and all
the other little animals too
but yeah uh sandra says my stream is
lagging
that's on you that's you that's that
well hopefully it's not
yes because i'm streaming it right here
through my [ __ ] tab it's perfect
yeah we don't seem to have a problem
with the lagging anymore since we got
the new uh
laptop with the that one that i'm using
just for that
all right this that that's probably
about that probably wraps this one up
really we covered it
yeah probably like i said this um you
know this is a really good if you like
psychological
horror like i said we sort of spoiled it
by saying what it was because i think
it's better like coming at it not
knowing what was happening because i
didn't really know where it was tiger
king saying that he refused to watch the
me bee's nest saying he's refusing to
watch tiger king no man watch tiger king
well because that dude is such a [ __ ]
bird he does like abuses cats
yeah it's not so not so much in the
movie though but you know you find out
later
yeah yeah he had too many goddamn tigers
and they did have like video of him like
kind of kicking them and yeah
beating on them sometimes but that not
it's not really they don't show that
much in the documentary yeah
although they do bring it up like people
kick that one cat because that cat was
[ __ ] biting him on the foot and
getting ready to eat him
remember that which you know and then he
shot everyone was like go tiger
shot the ground in front of the tiger
pow to try to get the tiger off of him
um and she did he got a i mean it came
out later
that he had too many tigers and he could
feed you know he he did
he was doing bad [ __ ] but that that
that series there [ __ ] blew my mind i
didn't i didn't know the people
that people existed like that almost
everybody in that was a terrible person
yeah and they're all and it's not just
them it's just
they're these tiger cults they're cults
you'll see
yeah there's a bunch of weirdos yeah
weirdos tiger cults
guys got all these tigers and if you he
built his own neighborhood and
with how with all these [ __ ] nice
houses on it
and each one of those house he had
another [ __ ] girlfriend in it he had
about nine girlfriends
or were they wives well they were wives
i guess
i don't know they weren't for him and
well unless you live in utah you can't
legally have
yeah it wasn't legally wise i don't even
think you could do it there he had a
whole harem of these young women and
they loved these [ __ ] tigers so he'd
just bring him in and the next thing you
know he'd adopt him
and he had like seven or eight of them
he and they had to get implants and they
had to [ __ ] wear tiger [ __ ]
costumes
the weird [ __ ] man just got to see it
man yeah
to believe it like i said they're all
just terrible people yeah my family was
also [ __ ]
into the horse business and horse girls
are kind of like that too there's
there's weird [ __ ] going on in the
[ __ ] equipment in the equine s
industry especially the english
equestrian stuff that they have around
here
the trainers and the students and horse
girls and horse women and
don't date a horse girl don't
don't get involved i never did i grew up
in it
you know i was [ __ ] doing uh hunter
jumpers and stuff
and equitation from an early age i got
pictures of myself at like six on
[ __ ] full horses jumping fences
i'm i'll have to pull that picture out
one of these days but i grew up in in
that scene in california because my mom
was into it
and it never really mystified me i i
just took it for granted you know i
i've just been a rider in either horses
or motorcycles my whole life
but it's just um i don't enjoy it as
much as motorcycles
it was something that was just given to
me as a child it's like you know your
parents make you
make you learn how to play piano it was
like that
but the girls that are into that [ __ ]
man they're [ __ ] weird man
real weird you're for some trouble if
you date a horse girl yeah
yeah most of them are mentally unstable
just saying they can't afford their
bills and [ __ ] i'm not i don't want to
talk about it
louie says uh i watched your horror book
review very good thank you
i've got a lot more of those i'm going
to start doing them every week like i
said i got a huge [ __ ] pile of books
back there that i'm going to review and
matter of fact i've already got
uh several other reviews already
recorded because i wanted to get a few
weeks ahead in case i got behind on some
of the books
that i'm reading you know but uh so yeah
hopefully people are like these people
seem to be liking them and
i had a few people like ask me to do
horror book reviews and i don't want to
do that so
you know yeah so i put that up earlier
today i reviewed uh anya alborn's if you
see her it's like a supernatural
horror shining meets the exorcists kind
of
story i guess like small town stephen
kanye type of thing but yeah so if you
have netflix um i'm not sure if it's
available in other countries
like for netflix but in the us they just
dropped one bedroom on there
and it's a really decent movie i mean i
really liked it a lot like i said i
liked the ending i liked all the acting
i liked how like creepy and weird it was
and i didn't like know exactly where it
was headed but like i said
uh you know trigger warning for for bad
should happen into kitties
and also um like i said it's kind of a
scientology thing even though that's
kind of a spoiler but yeah
um yeah so this has been kind of shorter
than usual but
i got [ __ ] to do he's got [ __ ] to do
yeah and uh
we'll be on here again tomorrow probably
reviewing another new movie because i
gotta find another one
uh later on tonight to watch so uh we'll
talk to you guys again tomorrow and bye